qui m'intéresse beaucoup parce que c'est
très très à la mode ai je vraiment votre
avis à vous alors vous n'êtes pas
concerné vous êtes magnifique mais c'est
ce qu'on appelle la star est nommé cup
parce que c'est sincère ou pas invité de
l'émission une ambition un thème sur m6
michèle bernier a tenu à pousser un coup
de gueule contre les diktats de la
beauté et l'actrice française qui
rejoint donc la longue liste de ces
stars qui prône le bien dans sa peau le
naturel à tout prix on parle notamment
de lady gaga qui s'est montré sans sens
voilà on a vu aussi des top models qui
se montre voilà le matin à 50 ans sans
maquillage
est ce que c'est une tendance elle ce
sincère ou hypocrite regardez faut tout
le temps ressembler à ce que quelqu'un
vous dit est ce qu'un marchand
cosmétiques vous dit avec mon 46 ma
chère 46,7 clay cette classe a traité ce
pareil
et elle a bien raison l'humoriste et
actrice michelle bernier de ne pas s'en
laisser conter le top model cindy
crawford il ya presque dix ans inciter
les femmes à se photographier telles
qu'elles sont au réveil sans maquillage
depuis le mouvement no make up s'est
répandue sion
pamela anderson jennifer lopez penelope
cruz madonna ont très récemment lady
gaga au cinéma dans l'écriture des
chansons se sont pas maîtres après
chanson
elles ont toutes eu le courage de se
montrer au naturel à toul échos presque
les gens que je rencontre me disent
qu'ils aiment m'avoir n'est qu'ils
aiment pas mon physique
sur internet c'est également une
tendance qui explosent comme avec enjoy
phoenix est là tout le monde est arrivé
les stars youtube euse de tutos beauté
qui se montre aussi en vrai je retrouve
aujourd'hui avec les visages se
démaquiller ou des filles encore plus
jeunes pas de maquillage
à moins d'avoir un pied dans la tombe
moi plus les jours à l'école je vais non
mais comme commenté en fait je veux
marquer d'abord protège occasions face
aux mouvements l'industrie cosmétique se
devait de réagir et bing coup de génie
l'invention du make-up nude ou
maquillage au naturel en gros cela
permet de se maquiller sans avoir l'air
d'être maquillée et maka dernier défilé
de victoria's secret' des filles qui
font semblant d'être nommé cup grâce au
make-up nude 918 dollars par fille
fallait oser
heureusement certaines femmes de
caractère ne cède pas à ce diktat de la
mode inversé fuck you on fait comment
vont confirmer les très élégante soeurs
kardashian alors le no make-up sincère
ou hypocrite
[Musique]
voilà sincère aux hypocrites sincère
pour daniel moreau pourquoi en tout cas
je voulais rebondir sur michèle bernier
si j'ose dire que j'adore
on peut se permettre parce que ça l'a
fait à la région et justement ça fait du
bien d'entendre ça dans tous ces
spectacles elle prône justement voilà et
ben oui on a cinq plus de 50 ans ont
fait plus de 46 et merde et et je
voulais revenir sur ça j'ai retrouvé je
me suis souvenu que marianne james avait
posé nue devant pas justement et ça
c'est aussi un message pour dire voilà
on peut être bien dans sa peau on peut à
ses côtés on élit son nez parce que le
jeu parce que sébastien des choses très
intéressant voilà sur les photos ça
hypocrite c'est hypocrite parce que moi
ça m'est arrivé plein de fois d'être en
bas de chez certaines célébrités de les
faire vraiment en au make-up peut
tellement horrible que même les journaux
ce palais passé et ils ont peur qu'elles
perdent leur compte et n'ont donc non un
top model français ya pas si longtemps
est vraiment c'était je n'ai rien dit et
ce qui ce que vous voyez sur les réseaux
sociaux en fait c'est quand même souvent
filtré à angers en ligue 1 certaine
manière mais nommée cas par an et on a
vu des photos de cindy crawford
notamment effectivement qui aujourd'hui
toutes ces filles c'est horrible qu'ils
ont été les plus belles du monde ça très
touchant qu'elle surmonte comme ça en
disant voilà le matin on n'est pas
maquillée humanité aujourd'hui
j'aimerais la vie de sophie thalmann
elle est quand même très belle elle a la
chance à son âge de justement si elle se
prend au naturel comme prêtre aussi
jolie c'est top
moi ce qui me fait rire j'aime bien
regarder des fois effectivement ce les
stars nommées cup parce que je me dis
bon mot final canton mais aussi au
naturel ça s'est passé derrière vous et
moi là on est hyper maquiller à sur un
bateau on est d'accord que tout ça dans
la vraie vie la vérité c'est park ou du
maquillage
le matin vous dire trahi je suis bien
sûr je suis pas maquillée je suis gay et
c'est là le hic et leurs associés j'ai
passé le cap des 40 voix très bien mais
elle voit là vous pourriez mettre une
photo vaut le matin on a les yeux un peu
mou fille de 13 ans vit passer de tout
temps après on va voir quand on est
photographié c'est pas pareil quand une
vraie vraie naturel et qu'on se voie en
se propageant temps sincère pour vous
pourquoi je suis là parce que c'est
sincère mais c'est d'autant plus facile
que souvent maintenant les stars mêmes
catalans no make up c'est joli pourquoi
elles font général du botox un peu
d'acide et ironique
elle met un petit filtre donc ouais
voilà donc ça paie sa montre qu'elles
sont plutôt bien conservée avec quelques
artifices mais ça ne s'est pas hypocrite
pourquoi myriam justement à contre-pied
de ce que vient de dire catherine cesser
totalement hypocrite dans la maison où
il ya des filles du botox bling bling et
c'est vrai pour sauver parfois des
photos les terres sont trop moche pour
les passer alors sur les français où en
sont les français passaient déjà en
reste le procès en plus on rit ce procès
qui est prévu super mouche une fois pas
la photo
ouais on est là mon dieu
je voulais travel bien sûr des mariés
merci monsieur aussi moi j'ai dirigé des
magazines comme le gade quand on dirige
à la magazine c'est de voir les photos
km les photographes et on regarde en
arrière comme ali revanche intel c'est
impensable
saha jeu que vous faites voter ça vous
rassure nature affaissement et magali
race est insupportable d'hypocrisie
parce que ces femmes là font ça pour
donner du sens
regardez je suis moins maquillée donc
intellectuellement je suis moins super g
c'est n'importe quoi effectivement une
belle femme démaquiller elle sera
toujours plus belle qu'une mouche
maquiller c'est hypocrite mondiale de la
santé oms tournages sauvages a remis
quatre bonnes lignes est il 55 % quand
même mis un retour au naturel
vous allez finir par trouver un mec plus
d'un an